fortunately there are still a handful of
voices
in sports that have not completely lost
it that actually
see what's going on here and see it
better than a lot of conservatives in
politics
charles barkley charles barkley was on
cbs talking about
sports i don't really remember exactly
what he was talking about and because
now when
all of our sports conversations somehow
come back to politics charles barkley
said you know this is a
this is a game this is a political
tactic
to divide americans man i think most
white people
and black people are great people i
really believe that in my heart
but i think our system is set up for our
politicians whether they're republicans
or democrats
are designed to make us not like each
other so they can keep
their grasp of money and power they
divide and conquer
i truly believe in my heart most white
people and black people are awesome
people
but we're so stupid following our
politicians whether they're republicans
or democrats
and their only job is hey let's make
these people not like each other
we don't live in their neighborhoods
we're all got money
let's make the whites and blacks not
like like each other
let's make rich people and poor people
not like each other
uh let's let's scramble the middle class
i truly believe that in my heart
this is obviously true this is a classic
tactic by the way
of corporations against unions i think
there were some leaked memos from amazon
about this
how the the trick to preventing
unionization
is to get all the workers to hate each
other because if the workers have
solidarity they'll unionize and then
you'll have to negotiate with them
so corporations have been employing this
for a long time and continue to employ
this today
marx tried to do this on the basis of
class he believed that
when the workers of the world united and
got together there would be a workers
revolution and it would overthrow
this sort of bourgeois capitalist
industrial system that didn't happen and
so marx in that way died of failure but
but his
ideological heirs the western marxists
cultural marxists neo-marxists whatever
term you want to use
they they recognized the the problem
that
that marx had i talk about this at great
length by the way in my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
because it ties directly into
political correctness wokism cancel
culture
again whatever term you want to use what
guys like antonio gramsci realized this
communist
italian politician and and marxist
theorist was that
the conservatives had a cultural
hegemony so the workers just did they
just didn't feel that oppressed right
they didn't they didn't know that they
were oppressed they were laboring under
what he would call a false consciousness
so what you had to do
was indoctrinate them obviously take
over the cultural institutions
but also you know
gin up certain other antagonisms this
was later
brought to fruition under the frankfurt
school the creation of critical theory
we now see
a derivation of that critical race
theory taking over classrooms and
corporate america
we we saw in the 1960s and 70s a lot of
left-wing
foundations recognizing that if you
could
gin up racial identity create whole new
identity groups
hispanics for instance it's a relatively
recent identity group
until very recently you had people from
central and south america they would say
i'm mexican i'm whatever
guatemalan i'm brazilian now there's
this idea that you're you're hispanic or
asian it's a new identity group they're
trying to create a new one in the middle
east
called mina middle east north africa
that one hasn't really caught on yet
it's like fetch and mean girls you know
the people
people just haven't made that one happen
but there was an explicit plan
to divide americans on the basis of race
because
there isn't really a class system in
america so race is the is the fault line
and if you can do that
then the people who are retaining power
can really manipulate people
and really maintain a hold on their
power that's what charles barkley's
saying
he's absolutely right and you're seeing
this by the way tyson
with what we were talking about earlier
in the show about the fear of death cult
the left has taken this to its perfect
conclusion
in the coronavirus revolution of the
last
year and a half whereby we're not even
just divided on
race or sex or class or anything like
that
we are now perfectly divided from
everybody
we now it's not just that white people
view black people as a threat to them
or black people view white people as a
threat to them we now
have been instructed to view every
single person that we come into contact
with
not as a dignified human being
possessing an immortal soul
whom we should love as we love ourselves
but as bags of germs
that are out there waiting to kill us
and if they so much as
breathe from behind that filthy cloth
covering
that a bunch of sheep have been
persuaded to wear by dr fauci
if they so much as breathe it that is as
though they were taking out a gun and
shooting us
that's how dangerous they are because of
coronavirus
it is a perfectly divisive strategy
and some people still go along with it
very bad idea
we we need to encourage you know the
thing i always liked about sports is
that people seem kind of grounded
they seem kind of normal it wasn't
highly ideological we need to encourage
the
the remaining common sense voices there
to speak up
draymond green drake is a basketball
player apparently i don't know who he is
i don't watch basketball
but draymond green made this great point
the other day he was talking about megan
repino
that crazy-haired lady from the soccer
team
who always whines that she doesn't make
enough money she's a millionaire she's
rich she's famous but she
no wow wow i don't make enough money for
playing a sport that not a lot of people
watch
and draymond green said you know lady
you got to quit your whining
it's very it's very unbecoming i'm
really tired of seeing them complain
about the lack of pay because
because they're doing themselves a
disservice
by just complaining you know and
they're not huh they're not just
complaining but they are because they're
not laying out
steps that they can take to change that
and so
it's coming off as a complaint because
the people that can change it
they're just going to continue to say
what a revenue isn't there
the revenue isn't there so if you don't
bring in the revenue
we can't up your pay they're going to
keep using that but the reality is as
true as that is
it's an excuse because everyone says we
support women
we support women empowerment we support
women in the workplace we
we do this for women we do ex for women
blah blah blah and everyone
uses it to their advantage yet these
women
are not using these people that are
saying those very things
to their advantage so then it just
becomes a complaint that falls on deaf
ears
of course of course this is absolutely
right because
everyone is going to point out it's just
obvious that women's sports
don't bring in the revenue that men's
sports bring in because men and women
are different and men are
just not as physically strong and
fast and buff as dudes and that's just a
fact of life so when you want to watch
people
racing for instance you want to watch
the fastest people racing well that's
men
when you want to watch people fighting
you want to watch the strongest people
fighting that's
men when you want to watch people
playing team sports
goes on and on so just quit whining lady
that's very unbecoming broadly speaking
pride is ugly vanity is ugly humility is
beautiful
we once knew this but we don't know this
now now
we've we've convinced ourselves as a
culture
that pursuing our own will outside and
in contravention of the moral order
is good somehow because we're breaking
the oppression of the more basically
we're breaking the oppression of the
moral order and liberating ourselves
from reality
liberating yourself not just from the
bond the unjust bonds that have
been put on you but but even from
reality itself you see the the
total expression of this in
transgenderism which is i will liberate
myself
from nature entirely from my own
most basic nature uh not a recipe for
success you know charles barkley though
he makes this point i mean we're all
seeing this that
this is a big business this big business
here the grievance industry
as draymond green might call it is is
big business
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you